[Música]
el presidente ucraniano volodymyr
selenski denuncia que las cientos de
muertes en lucha representan un
genocidio desde este suburbio de kiev
acusó a las tropas rusas pero moscú no
insiste en que todo es un montaje de
ucrania difundido por los medios
occidentales
rusia estaba abierta al diálogo honesto
con occidente el ministro exteriores
ruso serguéi lávrov señaló que hay
esperanza en las conversaciones con
ucrania y agregó que más tarde habrá
pronunciamientos sobre los señalamientos
por las muertes en lucha
el calentamiento global podría
incrementar en más de 3 grados celsius
si las políticas ambientales no cambian
así lo reveló el panel climático de la
onu en su más reciente reporte aunque da
luces de esperanza al decir que el
planeta tiene el potencial de disminuir
a la mitad las emisiones para 2030
bienvenidos a las noticias de france 24
yo soy maría clara calle y es un gusto
acompañarlos iniciamos con la actualidad
en ucrania el presidente de ese país
volodymyr selenski visitó la localidad
de butch a que ha estado en el centro de
la noticia desde que la alcaldía
denunció que más de 300 cuerpos fueron
hallados en fosas comunes luego de que
el ejército ruso se retirara de la
región de kiev el presidente aseguró que
cada vez es más difícil negociar con
rusia ante las atrocidades el mandatario
sostuvo que miles de personas fueron
asesinadas y torturadas e incluso
denunció que varios de los muertos
tenían las extremidades arrancadas para
selenski lo que ocurrió en muchas son
crímenes de guerra que cataloga como un
genocidio y
estos son crímenes de guerra y serán
reconocidos por el mundo como genocidio
ustedes están aquí pueden ver lo que
sucedió sabemos que miles de personas
fueron asesinadas y torturadas
desgarradas y violadas y asesinatos de
niños
y no solo se leen si está denunciando lo
que ocurrió en busán naciones unidas
afirmó que esto podría ser un crimen de
guerra y una grave violación a los
derechos humanos distracción la vocera
de la oficina de derechos humanos de la
onu pidió además investigar los hechos
previamente la organización human rights
wacht recopiló testimonios que probarían
que por lo menos cinco civiles fueron
ejecutados por los rusos en lucha y
también tienen reportes de violaciones
sexuales en las ciudades de chernin hiv
kharkiv y kiev además hoy la casa blanca
afirmó que moscú quiere fortalecer su
presencia militar en el este ucrania no
desplegando miles de soldados washington
anunciará nuevas sanciones esta semana
y ante los señalamientos moscú niega ser
responsable de la muerte de civiles en
busca y sostiene que todo es una
fabricación de los ucranianos tanto
quieres como el kremlin pidieron una
sesión en el consejo de seguridad de la
onu para discutir qué ocurrió sin
embargo hoy al ministro exteriores de
rusia serguéi lávrov anotó que reinó
unido- bloqueó la reunión extraordinaria
el canciller agregó que más tarde habrá
una de prensa desde naciones unidas
sobre muchas en cuanto a las
conversaciones con ucrania
lávrov señaló que siempre hay esperanza
e insistió en que moscú está abierto a
tener conversaciones honestas con
occidente pero que la negativa de estos
países de hablar de manera apropiada no
llevará a nada bueno el ministro agregó
que los señalamientos de joe biden quien
llamó criminal de guerra a vladimir
putin muestran que algunos políticos no
tienen conciencia
esto demuestra que muchos políticos
estadounidenses que estuvieron en los
orígenes de la guerra de irak por
motivos bien conocidos que desintegraron
libia con sus socios de la otan y que
invadieron siria esos políticos no están
del todo bien de conciencia su visión y
por supuesto yo ya comenzaron las
represalias por las muertes en lucha el
gobierno alemán anunció que expulsará a
40 diplomáticos rusos de la embajada en
berlín francia tomará la misma medida
contra 35 funcionarios de la embajada
rusa en territorio galo mientras que
lituania expulsara al embajador de rusia
y cerrará el consulado que tiene moscú
en la ciudad lituana de klaipeda el
ministerio exteriores ruso respondió que
pronto habrá un pronunciamiento sobre
las medidas y más allá de los
señalamientos entre los diplomáticos las
consecuencias de la guerra las están
sintiendo los civiles la onu estima que
más de 42 millones de personas han huido
de ucrania cerca de 400.000 cruzaron la
frontera hacia moldavia sin embargo este
país es uno de los más pobres de europa
una población de tan solo 26 millones de
habitantes por lo que recibirá miles de
refugiados es todo un reto nuestra
enviada especial tel bonet tiene la
historia desde la localidad moldava de
palanca
estamos en el paso fronterizo de palanca
en el lado de moldavia y aunque en estos
momentos no se ve mucha actividad ni
cruce de personas durante esta mañana
han salido decenas de ucranianos que
venían principalmente de la ciudad de
odessa después de que ayer hubiera
habido un bombardeo en una refinería
palanca se ha convertido en el centro de
recepción pero también de salida de
muchos ucranianos que quieren marcharse
a otros países de la región
especialmente rumanía porque es el más
cercano a quien palanca la gente ha
mostrado su solidaridad y ha dado
hospitalidad a muchos ucranianos pero
también empieza a tener miedo si la
guerra sigue avanzando es decir si las
tropas rusas siguen avanzando y llegarán
a tomar o de sap por lo cerca que está
de esta frontera y también porque
moldavia al igual que ucrania ha sido
una antigua república soviética y podría
repetirse o esperan que la guerra se
termine allí y no pueda seguir avanzando
las tropas rusas a este país
sigamos ahora con un breve recorrido por
otras noticias recientes de la guerra en
ucrania el equipo del comité
internacional de la cruz roja está
retenido en man jus un asentamiento en
la provincia separatista de donges que
el portavoz del organismo jason
straziuso explicó que el grupo intentaba
entrar a mariupol cuando fue detenido
pero no dio detalles de quién fue el
autor ucrania acusa a las fuerzas rusas
pero moscú dice que las evacuaciones han
fallado por problemas logísticos del 60
luego de la reunión de los ministros de
finanzas de la zona euro alemana
alemania advirtió que por ahora no podrá
parar la importación de gas ruso sin
embargo el país tomó temporalmente el
control de gazprom germanía la filial
que viene la compañía rusa en territorio
alemán diciendo que con esto intentan
garantizar la seguridad energética
moscú restringirá avisados a los países
que tilda de inamistosos este lunes el
presidente vladimir putin firmó un
decreto en represalia por las sanciones
impuestas por occidente la medida
aplicará en contra de funcionarios
diplomáticos delegaciones oficiales y
periodistas las naciones de la unión
europea noruega suiza entre otros
y cambiamos de tema porque esta década
será crucial para combatir el
calentamiento global así lo advirtió el
nuevo reporte de la onu realizado por el
panel intergubernamental de expertos
sobre el cambio climático ipcc los
científicos plantean que existe el
potencial para reducir a la mitad las
emisiones de gases de efecto invernadero
de aquí al 2030 algo que dicen que se
puede lograr por ejemplo plantando
bosques es estimulando el uso de
energías fósiles o limitando la
contaminación industrial sin embargo la
advertencia es clara si las políticas no
se fortalecen el calentamiento global
podría aumentar 32 grados celsius para
el año 2025 esto es casi el doble de la
meta que se propone el acuerdo de parís
de limitar el calentamiento a 15 grados
celsius
blooming estamos en camino hacia el
calentamiento global más del doble del
límite de 15 grados acordado en parís
algunos líderes gubernamentales y
empresariales están diciendo una cosa
pero hacen otras en pocas palabras se
están mintiendo y los resultados serán
catastróficos esta es una emergencia
climática los científicos del clima
advierten que ya estamos peligrosamente
cerca de un punto de inflexión que
podría conducir a impactos climáticos en
cascada e irreversibles y live earth y
volcán machín pets miles de trabajadores
de la salud y personal del ejército
chino viajaron este lunes a shanghai en
un llamado del gobierno para ayudar a
contener la propagación de kobe 19 los
más de 10.000 profesionales realizaron
pruebas para detectar el virus y
prestaron además asistencia hospitalaria
es que la metrópoli china podría
enfrentar el peor brote de coronavirus
que ha habido desde que empezó la
pandemia juan pabló lucumí nos trae
todos los detalles en el siguiente
informe
llegó la ayuda a shanghai desde
distintas provincias más de 10.000
trabajadores de la salud y 2.000 médicos
militares viajaron este lunes a la
ciudad más grande de china para ayudar a
realizar pruebas y ofrecer tratamientos
médicos contra el kobe 19 una estrategia
adicional desplegada en la ciudad que se
encuentra bajo un estricto confinamiento
sectorizado debido al aumento de
contagios atribuidos a la variante
omicron con más de 25 millones de
habitantes a la mayoría de los
ciudadanos de shanghai solo se les
permite salir de sus casas para
abastecerse de alimentos o para hacerse
pruebas masivas para lograr una
distribución sin contacto ponemos el
autodiagnóstico en la puerta de nuestros
vecinos y llamamos a la puerta o la
suite de prueba de antígeno se ha
colocado en la puerta después de la
prueba por favor coloque el lado con los
resultados y lo recogeremos
más hacia el sur en el territorio
semiautónomo de hong kong el brote de
kobe 19 ha cobrado la vida de más de
8000 personas desde el inicio de la
pandemia en donde más del 95% de los
fallecimientos se han registrado entre
febrero y marzo de este año una crítica
cifra de muertes que incluso ha
sobrepasado la capacidad de ataúdes de
los proveedores de la ciudad ahora las
empresas entregan féretros de cartón y
algunas ong han donado cientos de ellos
para la distribución en hospitales
públicos
en la sala de urgencias hay muchos
cuerpos que hay que guardar en bolsas
esto provoca dos problemas el primero es
que los profesionales médicos se están
quedando sin espacio y el segundo es que
para las familias de los pacientes o
para la gente en el hospital no es algo
muy agradable de ver dónde está
con su estricta política de 'cero cobit
el gobierno chino ha demostrado que
haría lo necesario para evitar la
propagación del virus mientras también
se niega a tener cierres totales en sus
ciudades evitando que se entorpezca la
economía nacional y las negociaciones
internacionales
en señalan acá se agudiza la crisis
política el partido de oposición más
grande llamado la fuerza del pueblo
unido rechazó la propuesta del
presidente gotabaya rajapaksa de hacer
un gobierno de unidad además este lunes
continuaron las protestas en contra de
la peor crisis económica que ha vivido
esta nación insular del océano índico
los manifestantes fueron a la casa de
raya pax ya a exigirle que renuncien y
es que el viernes el mandatario declaró
estado de emergencia y toque de queda en
todo el país para intentar contener las
masivas protestas esto le dio más
poderes a la presidencia como por
ejemplo detener personas y confiscar
bienes y también provocó la renuncia de
los 26 ministros del gabinete hoy
rajapaksa juramento a cuatro ministros
temporales mientras las protestas
continúan
[Aplausos]
en noticias de américa el recién electo
presidente de costa rica rodrigo chávez
hizo una de las primeras declaraciones
sobre qué hará en su gobierno después de
que fuera elegido en la segunda vuelta
electoral del domingo chaves indicó que
el acuerdo que tiene el país con el
fondo monetario internacional por más de
1.700 millones de dólares no fue lo
suficientemente ambicioso y anunció que
mantendrá el programa con el fm desde
que asuma la presidencia el 8 de mayo
uno de los grandes retos que enfrentar a
chávez es el deterioro de la economía
costarricense veamos más en el siguiente
informe de umar esa
estabilidad económica y bienestar social
esos son los principales desafíos del
recién electo presidente de costa rica
rodrigo chávez fue ministro de hacienda
durante apenas seis meses en la
presidencia de carlos alvarado su
partido progreso social democrático
tiene sólo tres años de fundado y no se
esperaba ni siquiera que superará la
primera ronda aún así fue el ganador
inesperado de unas elecciones que
arrojaron una abstención histórica
superior al 42 por ciento esto no
significa bajo ningún punto de vista que
los compatriotas que no acudieron a las
urnas no amen a costa rica ni a su
democracia ellos son probablemente los
más críticos y preocupados por el futuro
del país aceptó esa advertencia
como un compromiso para trabajar con más
fuerza y patriotismo por costa rica
el economista conservador que obtuvo
menos de un quinto de los escaños en el
parlamento necesitará generar amplios
consensos para cumplir con la promesa de
mejorar los indicadores sociales que una
vez hicieron de costa rica- un referente
en américa latina' con esta minoría
política con apenas 10 escaños sobre 57
como el gobierno podrá justamente llevar
a cabo la reforma fiscal que costa rica
necesita para poder aumentar sus
ingresos y por ende también tener
mayores recursos para generar mayores
políticas sociales
chávez también debe responder a
acusaciones e irregularidades en el
financiamiento de su candidatura y sobre
acoso sexual durante su paso por el
banco mundial luego de una campaña
caracterizada por la confrontación no ha
perdido tiempo para comenzar a tender
puentes no hay espacio para el
resentimiento menos para los
revanchismos o las confrontaciones
estériles
comprendo que en una campaña electoral
se dicen muchas cosas pero yo me he
comprometido
y me empeñaré en pulsar profundos y
positivos cambios en la forma de
gobernar costa rica-
democráticamente
reparar los daños que la pandemia
produjo en la economía fundamentalmente
en el turismo será la primera tarea que
chávez tendrá que atender desde el 8 de
mayo cuando asuma la presidencia
hasta aquí las noticias en france 24 los
invitamos a que sigan conectados con
nuestra programación ya que visiten
nuestra página web france24 puntocom nos
vemos pronto
[Música]